so we have barney pilling here who has
worked on films like the grand budapest
hotel one day and an education we have
Valero Benelli who's worked on Philomena
and hummingbird amongst many others
William Goldenberg who's here with the
imitation game and has also worked on
films like zero dark thirty and Argo and
Tom cross who is here this year with
whiplash oh good I think if you can talk
about what it is that initially draws
you to a project as an editor for me it
always starts with the script you know
in the case of whiplash I had a you know
producer I had worked with before when I
was an assistant editor was interested
in having me work on the short film
version of whiplash which preceded the
feature and he described it to me and
said it's gonna be a great opportunity
and I said something the script and you
know I read the script and I thought it
was just dynamite it was a fantastic
script and so I think it always almost
always starts with that but then I got
to then I said you know it's a fantastic
script I'd love to meet the director I
met the director and I thought he was
dynamite I thought he was fantastic I
mean the way we we kind of loved the
same films he literally spoke about
editing he talked about editing from
specific movies that he loved I could
just tell that this this was someone who
I really wanted to work with he really
had a vision for the movie
if this director Damien Chazelle if he
does any movie if he directs the phone
book yeah
not quite my tempo Connolly okay yeah
okay right away from the top I can do
nope
we'll go with Connolly now basically the
goal was to really get it to Sundance
and so they started shooting September
3rd and you know I I really I was
cutting while they were shooting I had
kind of a first assembly first cut week
after they finished shooting they shot
about 19 days and so on that movie we
really had very little time but I knew
that because the schedule was never
going to slow down I knew that I had to
get really in deep with the footage and
really get to know it and try things as
quickly as I could
these days I think everyone is used to
seeing very polished rough cuts very
polished and and so polished that you
they're not even really rough cuts in a
way and so on whiplash that was the case
I mean my goal was to really have a
first cut that was very polished at the
same time I always just look at it as a
sketch because I know that in my
experience a lot of things really change
once the director comes in the room
there was one time I remember where
Damien was really insistent that he shot
something and I was pretty certain that
he didn't but he was so certain that I
started second-guessing myself
as I think having my assistants look for
deleted it and write did I delete it or
did I just not see it which is a
nightmare and editors nightmare somehow
you didn't see something that's that's
never supposed to happen but as it turns
out you know I I felt confident in my
knowledge that what he thought he shot
didn't exist and I really only could
speak with confidence about that because
I knew the footage so well and he was so
insistent but I knew the footage so well
that I insisted and eventually he was
like oh yeah
oh yeah right it was that day and then
he started getting really depressed
because he missed a shot that we didn't
get but then we had to come you know
then we came up with a solution and and
and sort of jerry-rigged something
together and then you know it was okay
start counting it five six in four damn
it look at me one two three four one two
three no was i rushing or was i dragging
count again one two three one two three
one two three rushing or dragging russia
so you do know the difference only maybe
you could talk a bit about the grand
budapest hotel the script can be really
different particularly with the comedy
because it's so visual I mean it was
such a good script you know where Wes
has really honed his craft now and I
think it's almost out of the normal
ballpark of comedy he's got his own
brand of that and you know his sense of
timing and his sort of peculiar view on
human relationships is where the comedy
comes from I really responded to the
script but I think the other thing to be
said about Wes is manner of filmmaking
is and you it's evident from from
watching his films is that that's an
awful lot of physical humor going on not
just the way the characters interact
together which is obviously very
important but also the way those
characters react with the camera they're
so deliberate these camera moves and so
over in places they're often you know
the humor comes from from the timing of
those just as much as the characters do
that's not to say that it all just falls
together it doesn't and there's an awful
lot of time spent retiming and building
performances to have just the cadence
and but often you find that with these
sequences you know a gag will come at
the end of a series of cameras it's
whipped over there they've run they're
stopped it's whips up there and it holds
and there's a as your joke so it was it
was really well placed at script and
storyboard stage
maybe a third of you gentlemen by order
of the Commissioner of Police Sbrocco
province I hereby place you under arrest
for the murder of madame céline
villeneuve de Kaufman Texas I knew there
was something fishy we never got the
cause of death she's been murdered and
you think I did it hey William the
tension guy if you could talk a bit
about the specifics of the imitation
game while I was cutting the film I was
trying to always have in my mind that
you know because they're in this little
village and you know Bletchley Park
which is you know and they're with
mostly with pencils and pens and pads
and and that's how they're trying to
break the code and then eventually the
machine at Allen builds and but trying
to cut with a pace that made it feel
urgent and made it feel like there was a
race against the clock at all times I
made it you know it feel like there was
this tremendous weight of the war on
them at all times and we through the
course of cutting the film added you
know through CG and a couple little
extra pieces of voice-over stock footage
more war elements to sort of bring that
down on their heads a bit more and then
I think when Morton and I went through
the film and really concentrated on
getting that element right we realized
we took a step back and realized we had
sort of shortchanged the personal story
a little bit and we were really giving
benefit benedict the room to breathe and
the room to really you know to explore
it be able to explore his character and
in ways that we we had footage for so we
went back and and had it like eased up
on it a bit and really let those moments
play and and tried to make them as real
and as personal as possible and the
great thing with tonight after like
benedict is you can by just hanging on
him in certain moments and playing and
letting things play he delivers
performances that are so extraordinary
you can't take your eyes off him there's
a scene in the interrogation room where
he's talking where he's explaining what
the imitation game is that words I mean
it's just probably ten cuts in the scene
and
you know it's all just benedict and just
finding those performances and letting
them play a lot of those emotional
moments and those human elements were
just you know really really great acting
and just finding those moments and and
let even let the audience enjoy them
would you like to play play it's a game
a test of songs for determining whether
something is a machine or a human being
out of a play well that's a charge in a
subject the judge asks questions and
depending on the subjects answers
determines who he is talking with what
he is talking with and all you have to
do is ask me a question I'm afraid we're
out of time but that's been really
illuminating thank you all very much
Barney valaria William and Tom thank you
you
you